what i'd like to do in this video is use
some geometric arguments to prove that
the slopes of perpendicular lines are
negative reciprocals of each other
and so just to start off we have lines l
and m and we're going to assume that
they are perpendicular so they intersect
at a right angle we see that depicted
right over here
and so i'm going to now
construct some other lines here to help
us make our geometric argument so let me
draw a horizontal line that intersects
at this point right over here let's call
that point a
and so let me see if i can do that
there you go so that's a horizontal line
that intersects at a
and now i'm going to drop some verticals
from that so
i'm going to drop a vertical line
right over here
and i'm going to drop a vertical line
and so that is 90 degrees and that is 90
degrees and i've constructed it that way
this top line is perfectly horizontal
and then i've dropped two vertical
things so they're at 90 degree angles
and let me now set up some points so
that i already said point that's point a
let's call this point
b
let's call this point c
let's call
this point
d
and let's call this
point e
right over here
now let's think about what the slope of
line l is so
slope of let me
move this over a little bit
so slope
slope of l
is going to be what
well that's
you could view line l as line the line
that connects point c a
so it's the slope of
of c a you could say this is the same
thing as slope of
line c a
l is line c a and so to find the slope
that's change in y over change in x so
our change in y
is going to be cb
so it's going to be the length of
segment cb that is our change in y
so it is cb over our change in x
which is the length of segment ba
which is the length of segment ba right
over here so that is b a
now what is the slope of line m
so
slope
of m and we could also say slope
of we could call line m line
ae line
ae
like that
well if we're going to go between points
a and point e once again it's just
change in y over change in x well what's
our change in y going to be
well our change in y
well we're going to go from this level
down to
this level as we go from a to e we could
have done it over here as well we're
going to go from a to e that is our
change in y
so we might be tempted to say well
that's that's just going to be the
length of segment d e
but remember our y is decreasing so
we're going to subtract that length as
we go from this y level to that y level
over there and what is our change in x
so our change in x we're going to go for
as we go from a to e our change in x is
going to be
the length of segment
a d
so
so our slope of m is going to be
negative d e it's going to be the
negative of this length because we're
dropping by that much that's our change
in y
over segment a
over segment a d
so some of you might already be quite
inspired by what we've already written
because now we just have to establish
that these two
that these two are these two triangles
triangles c b a and triangle a d e are
similar
and then we're going to be able to show
that these are the negative reciprocal
of each other so let's show let's let's
show that these two triangles are
similar
so let's
let's say that we have this angle right
over here and let's say that angle has
measure x just for kicks and let's say
that we have let me do another
color for
let's say we have this angle right over
here
and let's say that the measure that that
has measure y
well we know x plus
y
plus 90 is equal to 180 because together
they are supplementary so i could write
i could write that
x
plus 90
plus 90 plus y
plus y
is going to be equal to is going to be
equal to
180 degrees if you want you could
subtract 90 from both sides of that and
you could say look x plus y are is going
to be equal to
90 degrees is going to be equal to 90
degrees these are
algebraically equivalent statements
so is equal to 90 degrees and how can we
use this to fill out some of the other
angles in these triangles
well let's see
x plus this angle down here has to be
equal to 90 degrees or you could say x
plus 90 plus what is going to be equal
to 180. i'm looking at triangle cba
right over here the the interior angles
of a triangle add up to 180. so x plus
plus what is equal to 180 well x plus 90
plus y
is equal to
180. we already established that
similarly over here y plus 90 plus what
is going to be equal to 180 well same
argument we already know y plus 90 plus
x is equal to 180. so y plus 90 plus x
is equal to
and so notice we have now established
that triangle
triangle a b c and triangle e d a
they're all of their interior angles
their corresponding interior angles are
the same or they and so or that their
three different angle measures all
correspond to each other they both have
an angle of x they both have a measure x
they both have an angle of measure y and
they're both right angle right triangles
so just by angle angle angle so we could
say by
angle angle angle one of our similarity
postulates we know that triangle
e
triangle
e d a
is similar to
triangle
to triangle
a b
c
to triangle a
b c
and so that tells us that the ratio of
corresponding sides are going to be the
same
and so for example
we know let's find the ratio of
corresponding sides we know that the
ratio of
let's say cb
to ba
so let's write this down we know that
the ratio so this tells us that the
ratio of corresponding sides are going
to be the same so the ratio of c
b
over b a
over
b a
is going to be equal to
is going to be equal to well the
corresponding side to c b
it's the side opposite the x degree
angle right over here so the
corresponding side to c b is side a d
so that's going to be equal to
a
d
over what's the corresponding side to b
a well b a is opposite the y degree
angle so over here the corresponding
side is d e
a d
over d e let me do that same color
over
d e
and so
this right over here
this right over here we saw from the
beginning this is the slope
this is the slope of l
so slope
slope
of l and how does this relate to the
slope of m
notice the slope of m is the negative
reciprocal of this you take the
reciprocal you're going to get d e over
a d and then you have to take this
negative right over here so we could
write this as the negative reciprocal of
slope of
m negative
reciprocal
of
of m's
of m's slope
and there you have it we've just shown
that if we start with purple if we
assume these line l and m are
perpendicular and we use and we set up
these similar triangles and we were able
to show that the slope of l is the
negative reciprocal of the slope of m